Real estate really,
really matters.
It's the biggest financial
and emotional decision
that the average
person will make.
Real estate's the largest
segment of the global economy,
and nobody loves it.
For many people it's hard
to wrap their head around.
By taking this class,
I'm going to demystify
the entire process for you.
I founded a real estate
technology platform.
Its sole mission is to make
real estate better for everyone.
There are a lot
of misconceptions
about the real estate industry.
It's an industry that
powers single parents,
people like my mom, who
from a very early age
made me a dreamer.
I saw her as an entrepreneur,
and it instilled in me
this desire to
create, build, dream,
and be an entrepreneur myself.
There's no blueprint
for buying a home,
but I am going to give you
some general guidelines of how
to approach it so that
you can be successful.
I'm going to give
you an insider tip.
When you're in an open house,
treat it like a flea market.
Try not to share
your enthusiasm.
You want them to see
how confident you are,
but not that you need this.
When you're a seller,
I highly urge you--
if you want to maximize
the value of your home,
make it move-in ready.
Homes that are move-in ready
sell faster than homes that
don't.
Being raised with a single
parent where my father passed
away when I was young;
I've been searching
for belonging my entire life.
I'm Black and Jewish, so
I never felt like I really
belonged in any category.
Part of the dream was I was
going to create a family,
and this family would
be great; but it all
comes down to that home.
A home is the culmination
of that belonging.
Home creates stability,
security, memories.
It's your place in the world.
At the end of this
class, I want you
to feel like you
could dream bigger,
that anything is possible.
Opportunity is
everywhere around you.
I'm Robert Reffkin, and
this is my MasterClass.